[Applause]
we want freedom we are going to get it
25 years ago
something remarkable happened in South
Africa Nelson Mandela's election as the
country's first black president marked
the end of apartheid it is a tile seeing
hey freedom is coming freedom is curvy
almost half the South Africans are part
of the Born Free generation the term is
used to describe those who never
experienced the legally enforced racism
of a party which ended with free
elections in 1994 I believe in the term
born free
I'm not held back from what I can do and
what I want to achieve within society
but there's still a long way to go
I am NOT born free I'm punching
I think that's born free identity was
part of some kind of marketing scheme by
brands South Africa to allow us into a
false sense of unity I guess I'm
classified as a born free but I don't
see myself as a born free it wasn't
really for people of my race you had to
fight to get this country to move
forward from apartheid to be classified
as a born free Mandela remains an
enduring global icon for peace but many
of South Africa's born free feel
conflicted about his legacy
[Music]
my experiences was very tough growing up
hot bay is one of the most segregated
places we have the blacks the whites and
the coloreds there's a lot of poverty my
father was in prison on Robben Island
with Nelson Mandela when he came to
power
Mandela presided over what many called
the rainbow nation where all could live
in harmony no matter what their race
Nelson Mandela's legacy was all about
bringing peace to communities but the
work is not done it's still in process
and all we talk about is the legacy of
Mandela we're taught about him as a hero
who emerges as the Victoria slaying
their birthday giant but that is not
what happened
it's not what happened compromised I'm
at its maker art maker I am maybe an
activist
the nature of the struggle that the
older generation our parents faced was
vastly different valves
but we are not lucky we were in pain if
they just listen and they just look they
will realize that very little has
changed just because I cannot live with
a white person you know I don't really
think about apartheid too much I had a
very fortunate upbringing my parents
were in a scenario where I could go to
one of the best private schools in the
country post 1994 I think my parents I
was he very hopeful of but there was a
fear about you know how the country was
going to go from this point on it
Mandela made a raft of pledges in his
maiden speech as president which would
go on to form the backbone of South
Africa's new constitution our greatest
responsibility after the election will
be to turn the suffering country into a
prosperous peaceful and democratic
society this means creating jobs
building houses providing education and
bringing peace and security for all the
promises of 1984 have not been kept for
example economic justice it did not
happen it's a lot more difficult to keep
a promise to free people economically if
you have invested in keeping the
economic power in the same place that it
was during apartheid which is with the
white business owners the white land
owners this is part of the agreements
that were made South Africa's levels of
inequality are among the highest in the
world the richest 10% own between 90 and
95 percent of all wealth a lot has
changed since part eyes there's a lot of
stuff in place to improve equality
the government has lots of policies that
favor black people in admission to
universities hiring in the workplace and
even share ownership it's an incentive
for companies to hire black people
colored people some of this falls under
the slogan of black economic empowerment
otherwise known as B EE there is a
certain amis ayat e that a few people
have that the B is just going to
disadvantage them because they're not
being looked at for for certain roles or
jobs or positions because of their race
I don't really know how true that is
whether it's a broad-based black
economic empowerment or affirmative
action what it kind of turned out to be
is that it only empowered the already
existing black elites an ANC government
will guarantee victims of forced removal
restitution this was one of the promises
that was made in 1994 the government
failed
during apartheid over three and a half
million black and mixed-race South
Africans were forcibly removed from
their homes and placed in segregated
neighborhoods in what was one of the
largest mass evictions in modern history
my parents and grandparents were evicted
from the land and thrown on another site
the government has tried to give some of
the land back to the rightful owners it
was never enough when I was 18 years old
I have the right to apply for a house I
had to go on the waiting list and my
number was five hundred and seventy
three thousand the current waiting list
for a state subsidized home in Cape Town
is 60 years we are fighting for freedom
colonised education now not in our
lifetime many of their youth is like
striking at universities because the
education system actually failed to
deliver in South Africa eighty percent
of children aged 9 to 10 and cannot read
and understand a simple sentence public
spending on education is high but many
teachers are incompetent or don't show
up to work then 2015 fees misrule
happens it's mass actions without free
education as one of the things that were
promised which was not given and they've
promised it again and I'm not giving it
Conde Swan now leads protests against
university tuition fees
so we do shutdowns a group of us get
arrested at some point we really feared
it felt like for our lives and our
safety there's anger and unrest on the
streets beyond University - police
brutality is playing a massive role
within the underprivileged communities
and they will just come in and start
shooting
there was a fourteen-year-old boy that
was shot in the mosque I captured on
camera
the ANC the party which Nelson Mandela
led to power has ruled for 25 years
widespread corruption especially under
former President Jacob Zuma has stalled
economic growth sent public debt soaring
and increased unemployment for a lot of
people if I speak honestly there isn't a
massive amount of faith in you know the
people running the country the
government at this point our task as
young people is to find ways to
implement our potential
[Music]
recent polls reveal the only 14% of
South Africans have faith in the
government the country's leaders face a
daunting task in winning back their
confidence
my own food the future is that everyone
should be treated equally but the
grassroots is way the healing needs to
take place when it comes to apartheid I
think a lot of people tend to see it as
this massive inhibitor that's gonna hold
the country back but I truly believe
South Africa is going to make it one day
[Music]
you